[Music]
humans have incredible eyes
we can sense shapes depth and brilliant
colors
but a hallmark of our vision is
processing images
from both eyes on both sides of our
brain at the same time
something known as bilateral visual
projection
all mammals are capable of this type of
vision but fish were thought to have a
scaled back version
visual information from one eye projects
only
to the opposite side of the brain that
led scientists to think that bilateral
vision emerged more than 375 million
years ago
when fish moved from water to land such
vision
could have been an advantage to four
limb tetrapods that hunted and
lurked in the night but is this really
what happened
or were scientists just a little too
eager to take the bait
to test the old theory researchers
turned to modern techniques to study
fish's visual systems
first they selected fish from two pools
one group
teleosts make up 95 of all living fish
taleos separated from the rest of bony
fish 300 million years ago
after their entire genomes were
duplicated
some think this gave rise to the
astounding diversity seen in these fish
the other group some of which are
referred to as living fossils
are known as non-teleosts these ancient
looking fish are more closely related to
humans
to find out which fish had bilateral
projection scientists
injected fluorescent tracers into their
eyes
one color for the left eye and another
for the right
they tested seven teleosts including a
mud skipper
which spends most of its time above
water and
a large scale four eye which can see
above and below water
at the same time they also tested four
non-teleosts
including a sturgeon spotted gar and an
australian lungfish which can breathe
air
two days later researchers remove the
brains of the fish
and examine them with a specialized 3d
fluorescence microscope
bilateral vision works in mammals when
bundles of neurons in the retina send
information from
one eye to both sides of the brain they
found that in most teleosts
these bundles of neurons sent
information to only
one side of the brain the opposite side
but in non-teleosts the bundles
projected that information to
both sides of the brain like mammals
some of their neurons sent even more
information to the same side of the
brain than mice
surprisingly the gene linked to
same-sided projection in mammals was
missing from non-teleosts but the
existence of bilateral vision
in non-teleosts suggests that it emerged
early in evolution
and didn't coincide with the transition
from water
to land which begs the question
how did bilateral vision give fish an
advantage
to find out scientists plan to find the
gene behind same-sided projection
in non-teleost fish and test how
removing it
impacts their ability to see if they're
successful
our fish ancestors could soon school us
with new
theories on how human vision evolved
even as old ones vanish
before our eyes
[Music]
you